we begin with some breaking news from
equatorial guinea where a series of
large explosions has rocked the city of
bata
the country's health ministry says at
least 17 people have been killed in
blasts
at a military base hundreds more are
injured an urgent appeal for blood
donations and volunteer helpers has gone
out
with area hospitals overwhelmed
for more on this developing story let's
bring in our correspondent fred
mouvounie who has been following the
events from lagos
in nigeria fred the country's president
has released a statement regarding
the cause of the explosions what does it
say
president obiang anguema has said in a
statement
that the explosion was neglected
negligence related to a dinah mite at a
military base
basically that's that's his reason but
that also means that uh the government
or the military
are responsible of what uh happened
today
it's very early to draw conclusions of
course what is the situation
on the ground there fred
so far about 17 people have been
reported dead but there are multiple
reports saying that
this the death toll can go up
because they believe that some people
are still under the rubble
and um 400 or more than 400 people
are reported injured so so far
that's the situation at the moment but
people believe that
these numbers could go higher after
they have tried or um after the people
emerging services have tried to rescue
people
maybe by tomorrow we'll know more about
what is
actually happening and the extent to how
these explosions have
affected the people of uh this small
city
this happened in the country's biggest
city bata what can you tell us
about the place
well bata is a port city on the mainland
of
kotori genie it has about 300
000 people uh of course electoral regime
is a
small country with just 1.4 million
uh population um it's it's the main hub
economic hub
and we believe that people have been
affected in a big number simply because
they are
they live together this is where most
people
in the country actually live compared to
other cities
in equatorial genie and this actually
happened
in the military camp it's
normally it's not rare that military
camps are in the middle of
uh population but in equatorial genie
that's the case especially in this
town of butter dw correspondent fred
mabuni thank you very much for your
update